la noche de miércoles a jueves estuvo
nuevamente marcada por una serie de
ataques en las ciudades más importantes
del donbass al menos estas ciudades que
todavía siguen bajo el control de las
fuerzas o craneanas la ciudad de
crematorios la más grande de la zona fue
atacada con varios misiles uno de ellos
cayó en una escuela y a esta hora se
siguen buscando si hay víctimas debajo
de los escombros pero también volvió a
caer en esas grandes fábricas de la
ciudad que son algunas de las fábricas
más importantes y ucrania estos ataques
también se extendieron a la ciudad de
bakú donde hasta ahora también se
evalúan las consecuencias de estos
ataques que habrían alcanzado el mercado
local y en la ciudad de constantino cada
una ciudad más pequeña cerca a la ciudad
de bakú diagrama thor que está entre las
dos y que se había convertido también en
una especie de ciudad paso para los
militares que estaban en la zona estos
ataques también se extienden a la zona
de jarc y para esta región que ha sido
atacada desde el comienzo de la guerra
una ciudad
el completo azote de las fuerzas rusas y
quedó bastante destruida las fuerzas
rusas habían sido expulsadas de la
ciudad de sus alrededores se han hecho
retroceder pero los ataques continúan
anoche volvió a ver uno nuevamente y dos
personas habrían muerto